і потім до наступних питань коротко ваш
коментар ми ми знаходимося на постійному
контакті з нашими колегами на Луганщині
і звідти йде просто жахлива інформація
на думку очевидців бойовики проросійські
обстріляли населені пункти так званими
трасуючими кулями які спровокували
страшну пожежу це літо було дуже таким
засушливим для Луганщини жодного дощу і
власне десятки тисяч ге
лісу зараз знаходиться в цій пожежі 11
сілв знаходиться в колі вогню загинуло
троє людей четверо знаходяться в лікарні
і власне 146 таких джерел вогнищ треба
потушити І власне в цей час Влада да
говорить про те що триває 64й день
перемир'я не помічаючи звіти СММ ОБСЄ
які розповідають що за ці два місяці
більше тисячі було режимів порушено
режим тиші І власне тепер ми бачимо що
Росія перейшла на новий такий
цинічний механізм гібридної війни Коли
просто знищення українських населених
пунктів цивільних іде через пожежу пані
Ірино Ну і питання щодо власно ситуації
з тристоронньою контакрактною групою по
Мінську відставка Фокіна як її оцінює
європейська Солідарність що стало її
причиною насправді і як вам кандидатура
пана лубківського Маркіяна як можливого
речника цієї
групи
А я думаю що в комплексі треба
розглядати питання щодо мирного
врегулювання на Донбасі і ось ці пожежі
вони не є випадковістю очевидно що
тільки Росія яка здійснює збройну
агресію на сході України вона регулює
коли прикрутити там трошечки вогонь а
коли додати туди бензинчику от зараз
вона додала бензинчику через пожеже А до
того був місяць такого прикручування
емоцій тому що випустили Фокіна на маніж
для того щоби він виконував тільки одну
роль озвучував ті бздури які насправді є
в Головах офісу Президента про те щоби
насправді перевісити оцю Московський
сценарій про начебто гібридне е
громадянську війну в Україні а незбройну
агресію і спробувати просунути
політичний спочатку блок так званий
Мінських угод перед безпекови і перед а
гуманітарним звільненням заручників Я
хочу нагадати що поки Фокін блукав по
ефірам і оце викликав на себе вагонь ну
своїми просто ніснітницями Кравчук В цей
час направив до Верховної Ради листа з
вимогою а внести зміни до українського
законодавства до постанови Верховної
Ради Про вибори Власне це був російський
сценарій очевидно тому на ньому ж
росіяни наполягали в Мінську І от дуже
цікаво що Серед таких скупих фраз
офіційного повідомлення про останню
відеоконференцію тристоронньої
контактної групи просочилося що
гризлов абсолютно відверто вже
шантажуючи українську сторону погрожував
що вони викинуть в паблік а незаконне
записані розмови які вони фіксували на
відео і знімали записували власне от я
працювала в Мінській групі ми знали в
тому президент отелі в Мінську що 100%
делегацію пишуть як мінімум дві дві
спецслужби ФСБ Російської Федерації і
Білорусі що одна і та сама спецслужба і
тому переговори треба вести так щоби не
було соромно А навпаки можна було чим
пишатися як ти захищав країну якщо їх
викинуть в Павлік Інше питання що це вже
порушення будь-яких міжнародних норм і
стандартів коли гризлов зізнається своїм
візові не тільки українцям а й ОБСЄ що
їх писали фільмували і зараз їх будуть
шантажувати цими записами таке можливо
тільки коли країна Сла ла коли делегація
слаба і це можливо тільки тому я думаю
що там такого намолотили на тих
зустрічах і таких на себе набрали
зобов'язань по політичному блоку
поприймати в парламенті що зараз Росія
буде цим шантажувати Кравчука а значить
і українську групу і Україну І власне
Моя порада мінським учасникам цих груп
ніколи не береть на себе ті зобов'язання
які вони можете виконати А що стосується
речника Мінської групи дивіться туди
входить три народних депутати України
пан Костін па Пан мерешка пані
третякова там працює віце-прем'єр з
питань реінтеграції Навіщо це речник
Вибачте я переконана що ці люди мають
фах і всі необхідні для того дані для
того щоби самім щиро і чесно розповіти
країні що відбувається в Мінських групах
Мені так здається що ж дуже дякую вам
пані Ірина Геращенко заступниця голови
фракції європейська Солідарність
включала
до нас в ефір ми тим часом